I saw you spying on me earlier  [Music]  see  [Music]  who moves out in the middle of the night  nothing strange about it she wanted to  leave how does that not make sense I  don't understand why and she didn't tell  me maybe she didn't like you maybe she  knows you're poor and haven't paid your  rent founder some kind of code or like  secret message in her department son you  can mean it stay quiet our world is  filled with codes subliminal messages  from Silver Lake to the Hollywood else  could any of this be connected to Sarah  I know this girl there's a message in  the music can't quite see it this  information is what we are told it is  maybe there are people out there who are  more important than us powerful  communicating things in the world that  are meant for only then but not for us  yeah oh you think that's weird  a little  [Music]  welcome to purgatory good to be here  you're living in a carnival hoping to  win a prize  what you gonna win  under this  [Music]  [Music]